[Music]
the city of buffalo is mourning the 10
people who were gunned down at a grocery
store in a predominantly black
neighborhood three others were hurt and
one of those killed was 86 year old ruth
whitfield she's a mother she's a wife
and she's a grandmother her son garnell
whitfield is a retired commissioner of
the buffalo fire department he joins us
along with attorney ben crump who is
representing the whitfield family good
morning to you both
mr whitfield i want to start with you
because we are also very sorry that you
and any other family is going through
this pain this morning but i'm curious
it's been reported that you went to the
store to help and once you arrived you
learned that your mother was in fact one
of the victims how did you find out that
you had now been personally affected by
this
my mom had gone to the nursing home
which he did every day for the last
eight years to uh care for my father who
was at the nursing home
and uh she didn't answer her phone and
the nursing home is just blocks uh from
the scene here uh upon her not asking
her phone uh just walked the scene here
and was able to ascertain that her
vehicle was uh in the lot here at this
store
garnell you mentioned your mother
visiting your father in the nursing home
tell us a little bit more about their
relationship
my
my parents were married for 67 68 years
we were wonderfully blessed to have uh
have them
all at this time
my father had taken neal and had
been
in this nursing home for the last eight
years
my mom
was there every day to take care of my
father every day she loved them
completely and she was doing what she
did every day
and she left there and stopped by the
store on the way home to get groceries
and encountered this individual
and ben i would like to ask you about
the representation of the ruth
ruth whitfield family in a statement
yesterday you said we are thoroughly
investigating the shooting and the
events leading up to it
what further answers do you want to know
well nate it's important that we not
only hold accountable
this individual who committed this
hateful act but we hold accountable
those who curate this hate who
radicalized these young white
supremacists i mean that manifesto he
said his intent was to kill
as many black people as he could that
day we saw in charleston south carolina
with the young white supremacist dylan
roof and now we're here in buffalo new
york how long before we get the
anti-black hate crime bill passed
because if we don't do something
meaningful nate and gail
i am so afraid that we will see
something like this happen again in our
communities
i i think i think ben trump were all
afraid of that you know it doesn't seem
like you're safe at the grocery store
the church at the spa at a movie theater
at a concert and now we have a man in
custody what do you make of the arrest
of this young man
you know
gail so many times we talk about unarmed
young people of color being killed but
yet when you have these
young
confirmed white mass murderers they
always seem to be taken alive
and so it just
goes to a deeper conversation
of uh how we deal with societal issues
especially involving race we have to
direct our attention to these internet
sites that inspire these young people
that are radicalizing them to be
hate-mongers to be people who hate
people because the color of their skin
it is very hard ben to hear that this
young man was so young and had so much
hatred in his heart
i want to go back to you mr whitfield
because you know i think about the 10
families who are waking up today whose
lives are forever changed i'm wondering
how you're processing this loss yourself
it's very difficult this is surreal we
we are
we are in a place that we never expected
to be
um my mother was the glue that held us
together my mother was my father's
caretaker
we've not shared this information with
my father we don't know if that's in his
best interest we we don't know how to
proceed uh we have to consult with his
caretakers with his doctors and find out
uh you know how to proceed with this we
don't know if he should attend the
memorial service for my father we don't
know how we're going to care for him
going forward in a manner consistent
with what my mother uh would have wanted
and so we are
we have a tough a tough road ahead it's
difficult days i think not just for your
family but for the country there's some
very difficult questions we all need to
face and we all need to answer we thank
you both thank you both